tortue à propos de vos chansons j'ai lu
quand même des critiques très dures haye
sur vous j'ai lu enfer et damnation
voilà qu'elle chante vont j'ai écouté
par deux fois s'il avait créé un livre
on aurait pu la métro le mettre au feu
ou ne pas l'acheter mais un disque les
télés vont nous la traque et vous avez
lu ces choses là où mon nom et ça vous
aurait fait arrêter ou sa non je vous
dis tout ce qu'il voit moi j'ai rien
contre les critiques parce que je pense
que on a besoin des critiques voilà
alors entre parenthèses si les critiques
étaient venus voir le spectacle et iso
de paris j'en aurais quand même moins
souffert il m'aurait été alors j'étais
tout seul parce que on invitait vous
savez c'était la map qui était là dedans
on a monté ça comme ça donc on était
tout seul et moi j ai invités et des
metteurs en scène il a mis des comédiens
les gens ne sont pas venus parce que il
même tronçon il ya le foll encore nous
faire quelque chose on serait papa lui
dis donc
ils ont eu tort mais les critiques
encore plus tort parce que les mythiques
on en a besoin
moi j'ai jamais eu maille à partir des
critiques au contraire mais c'est vrai
vous avez été éreinté sur son spectacle
non j'ai pas été éreinté par les
critiques quand elles polluent alors
comme ça on est tranquille non le jour
que je veux juste dire à propos de ce
que vous dites là est ce que se sont dit
regretter noms sont pas des gens
critiquent qui viennent voir une pièce
ça m'étonnerait ça m'étonnerait les gens
disent tout mais ce sont des gens c'est
autre chose c'est des gens des vecteurs
place comme ça qui sont has pernaut mais
ce ne sont pas des traités des critiques
pour moi j'ai toujours eu beaucoup
d'admiration et beaucoup de respect
qu'on n'aurait jamais engueulé quelqu'un
parce que c'était mauvais et j'ai jamais
été embrassée si j'étais embrassé ce
n'est pas une critique mais qui m'a fait
un petit papier mais ça m'a fait chaud
au coeur
d'ailleurs la même façon e mail vous
êtes critique puisque vous vous avez
quand même 10 20 journaux un jour j'en
ai eu marre de tourner des navets donc
c'est que vous
c'était osé même si vous l'avez j'ai pas
d'idée n'avaient non c'est parce que
j'ai dit on à défendre oui oui souvent
mais c'était aller dire à propos des
critiques et du mal que ça fait donc un
jour je jouais l'idiote je me souviens
est tellement j'étais traumatisé parce
qu'on allait c'est jean jacques gauthier
etc alors on allait au petit matin 1
place du châtelet pour avoir l'appétit
et babel mais j'y suis pas allé parce
que même même si elles sont bonnes quand
tu fais du théâtre
tu sais le comédien quand il fait un
truc qui va pas il le sait le premier
elle n'a pas besoin des critiques ou
quoi que ce soit mais lui il faut qu'ils
continuent alors même si tu lui même une
critique qui peut être bonne mais de
toute façon ça peut quand tu le film est
fait un film tu t'en fiches n'est pas
une pièce une pièce il faut aller au
théâtre est alors moi je n'évite pas
voilà c'est définitif déjà depuis au jeu
par 25 ans je n'y puis critique alors
toute façon que le diras tu sais oui
libre ou si vous voulez mais ça moi je
suis dans la citadelle c'est à dire que
toutes les critiques
ils ont voulu me faire mal ils peuvent
pas parce que mur de béton ou vacances
alors au top dans la gueule vous avez
été